alors les circonstances vont être
établies par l'enquêté ce qu'on sait
pour le moment c'est que c'est
vraisemblablement une altercation entre
automobilistes qui a eu une issue
tragique suit effectivement un différend
entre deux personnes qui sur la route
aura eu des soucis au niveau de la
conduite automobile
un coup de couteau mortel c'est ça c'est
ça donc
le conducteur du véhicule qui s'est
arrêtée la personne mise en cause a
porté un coup de couteau
effectivement à la victime mais pas plus
de précisions il je connaissais alors
pour le moment aucun élément d'enquêté
ne va dans ce sens là bien évidemment
l'enquète va vérifier ces éléments mais
dans les premières explications donnés
les premiers éléments recueillis aucun
élément ne permet de dire qu'ils se
connaissaient alors la personne ne s'est
rendu au commissariat
la personne s'est rendue immédiatement
dès qu'elle a eu le sentiment d'avoir
blessé sa victime sans savoir bien
évidemment qu'elle était décédée c'est
randy immédiatement d'elle même au
commissariat et a expliqué effectivement
très rapidement les circonstances des
faits
aujourd'hui elle est incarcérée elle est
incarcérée à à chalon donc une ouverture
d'information s'est faite vendredi
plus exactement samedi matin suite aux
éléments d'investigation vendredi
la personne a été secouée et bien
évidemment le juge d'instruction va
poursuivre les investigations
il faut fil de cette personne est ce
qu'on peut parler d'un règlement de
comptes aux autres non alors à ce stade
la vienne permet de parler de règlement
de compte c'est une personne qui n'était
pas connu des services de la justice qui
est une personne qui était inséré
socialement
il a aussi bien évidemment les
vérifications personnalité de son profil
de ces activités vont être poursuivis
mais à ce stade rien ne permet de parler
de règlement de comptes
est-ce que vous lancez un appel à
témoins alors les enquêteurs ont déjà
commencé à lancer un appel à témoins ont
pu entendre un certain nombre de témoin
qui était sur les lieux mais qui n'ont
pas vu la scène qui ont vu simplement le
véhicule de la victime arrêté sur le
bas-côté et bien évidemment ces
investigations se poursuivent